this morning on the dish london chef
claire smith
her notting hill restaurant core by
claire smith was awarded three michelin
stars this year
making her the first british female chef
to hold that distinction but with fine
dining put on hold during the pandemic
smith was able to expand her clientele
launching a delivery service
that allows desperate diners to
replicate her meals at home
as elizabeth palmer found out
today everything has to be perfect
a last-minute pass with a dust buster a
final tweak of tableware
and ties chef claire smith is about to
reopen her london restaurant core after
six long months of lockdown getting the
guests into the kitchen to say goodnight
is really important too
this is a triumphant return for smith
back in january at a covid safe zoom
ceremony
she won one of gastronomy's highest
awards
a huge congratulations to claire smith
from restaurants
[Applause]
smith is the first british woman chef
ever
to win three michelin stars i just want
for the future that
young chefs male female everyone in
britain has the opportunity to own their
restaurant and achieve
success she began life as an irish farm
kid
and a keen rider but fell in love with
food and cooking
early on it's a way of life it's
something that i've always done
you know i've been a chef since i was 16
years old i love it
even before she opened core smith had
been quietly
wowing london diners working for someone
far more famous what are you doing just
what the [ __ ]
are you doing remember gordon ramsay the
foul-mouthed celebrity star of reality
tv's hell's kitchen
and get out claire smith ran
one of his michelin-starred restaurants
for over a decade and he loved both her
talent
and her grit claire smith is like the
margaret thatcher
of cooking you know firm hard ass bloody
brilliant
the admiration is mutual gordon was
always supportive he was always
fair i wouldn't call gordon my friend
but i would call him my mentor
privately she dreamed of opening her own
restaurant
and in 2017 she made the move with core
by claire smith and a cheerful kitchen
with plenty of women
that runs like clockwork welcome hi
welcome
hi welcome 50 of my team are females and
i
do know that for a fact that it makes a
better workplace having a balance
growing up in those sort of difficult
kitchens and those testosterone-driven
kitchens everyone
played a part of being that tough guy
you know
and actually not everyone is coors
food and atmosphere soon earned more
accolades
and loving devotion from customers which
included
meghan markle and prince harry
in fact they hired smith to cater the
royal wedding reception
then came the pandemic when it shot
london restaurants down
smith retooled
if customers couldn't come to core core
would go
to them with pre-prepared gourmet food
delivered right to the door hello hello
ready to assemble and heat at home
we decided to give it a whirl with my
daughter chloe a sous chef
and smith coaching from youtube
hello and welcome to core at home in
this video i'm going to show you how to
bring together
all the items on your menu
[Music]
we may have been more keystone cooks
than food prep pros
but the result amazing
was sublime in fact
core at home was such a hit it's
attracted new
customers to the restaurant to savor
smith showcasing
british produce herbs grown in the
parking lot
behind the restaurant and there's time
time you know you've got time flowering
here as well
and ingredients arriving from across the
united kingdom
are these the hand-dive scallops you
tuck so these come from the isle of mull
these scallops will all be about eight
to ten years old
from the fishermen to the apple growers
smith
knows them all personally even the
farmer who grows the potatoes for her
signature dish
he literally drives into london and
drops the little bags of potato
off about two in the morning inspired by
smith's irish upbringing
this is a potato marinated in seaweed
and finished with trout roe butter sauce
and my favorite childhood snack which is
salt and vinegar crisps it is possibly
the most
delicious thing i've ever put in my
mouth
oh that's a revelation
chorus cuisine is as beautiful as it is
delicious
smith insists that her kitchen staff
earned the three new stars
just as much as she did to be a part of
a team that's won three
of stars is something that's so rare and
they have it for the rest of their
careers
down in coors wine cellar there's a
magnum of champagne which smith has
saved for the team to celebrate their
michelin star's
postcovid all together so that's going
to be some party
it is going to be a big party and then
it will be back to work because this is
more than a job
it's a mission we cook for our customers
it's not about those stars or those
awards it's when they walk out the door
the biggest award for me is they've
really enjoyed themselves
they think they've had a great time and
they want to come back
for cbs this morning saturday i'm
elizabeth palmer
in london and she's smiling from ear to
ear
the great liz palmer with her first dish
i know that was fantastic
first trip to london whenever it happens
now post pandemic i'm going there
somehow getting a resume yeah
firm hard ass pretty brilliant you gotta
love that although those little portions
i don't like that
you can just have more second seconds